what we'll do is we'll look at lots of  them and so it was at a hundred and  eighty thousand well we ended up at  about looking constantly for about a  hundred fifty thousand awesome  so the Kepler telescope had a big field  of view we could watch a hundred fifty  thousand stars what we did was he sent  it up there pointed it and went one  direction in space and this carefully  selected part of this guy and we just  stared at it for four years because you  have to watch for those dips which in  the case of the Earth orbit only happens  once a year  so you had we had to stare at that once  but once by this guy for four years and  you had to move the telescope so that it  would it would stay yeah exactly we had  we had to make very sure that the  telescope stayed very still yeah